make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking back up again
with
ten of swords and in this one we are
starting with the beginning of the of
the great big huge the gravy huge event
right the tournament right they're gonna
be huge battle but before we do we pick
up in the aftermath of wolverine
killing saturnine right we saw that at
the end of the last video that wolverine
popped his claws had enough of all of
her nonsense and just
impaled that girl and yeah following
that wolverine doomed the world
he basically killed the world that we're
we're told this in a couple different
ways the first one is in a bit of a kind
of opening prologue
of all the different things that are
going on in the immediate aftermath and
the second is what we're actually shown
here right so what we're told
is that what ended up happening is that
with the death of saturnine that
basically all hell began to break loose
right the external gate was was
essentially closed uh that arguments
kind of went about the quiet council in
terms of what they were going to do what
they were owed to otherworld with
regards to the death of saturnine right
the quiet council again is the council
that governs krakowa so at this point
they're kind of cut off from uh from
other world but the the conversations
were exceedingly short and the reason
why was because the external gate
immediately broke open and when it did
all the armies of morocco came pouring
out led by the four horsemen of
apocalypse led by
apocalypse's kid that they basically
managed to find a way to control ammon
and in turn control all the forces the
all the amenthy forces so all those
demons and they just kept
pouring out the difference here is that
while the x-men do have the ability to
resurrect dead it takes time to do that
whereas the forces of morocco had the
forces of ammon and so they just
basically had this endless horde of
monsters that literally poured into
krakowa
and then the rest of the world and that
ten thousand it was it was something
like ten thousand or thousands of of
x-men
of mutants basically died before a call
for help could even be made now when the
call for help went out that you ended up
seeing like the avengers the fantastic
four
the entire host of asgard who all came
in response to that the other thing
that the the forces of morocco did is
they detonated what was essentially a
telepathic mind bomb which literally
ripped through the mutant's higher brain
function so anybody who was telepathic
dead anybody with higher level thinking
was essentially wiped out right the
forces of asgard the forces of the
avengers the forces of the fantastic
fork were all destroyed
by the forces of morocco and so what you
end up picking up here
is just this entire place laid waste
right new york the world itself
completely conquered right the home of
doctor strange right the sanctum
sanctorum totally destroyed dr strange's
lifeless body
thrown out of the window right so for
the most part it's all completely been
conquered
and the only person who is left to
witness all of this right the the
beheading of apocalypse him being drawn
in quarter the fall of the world was
wolverine who was quite literally
crucified right just kind of stuck up on
this this great big huge platform
and left there but then he's immediately
or at least eventually met by the
arrival of saturnine and what we find
out is this is a gift that saturnine is
giving him this is her basically telling
him
this is what will happen if you fail
right if you if you were to successfully
kill me
this is what would happen if your team
loses the tournament this is what
happens if you fail
to win this to defeat to hold back the
forces of kokoa
this is the faith that awaits your world
everything will fall
and everything will burn now under
normal circumstances i will say
it was it on the surface it seemed a
little bit disappointing that it was all
just kind of a ruse i expected it to be
i didn't actually expect saturn
to fall this early it would have been a
pretty interesting scenario if she had
but it's also been established well in
the beginning of x of sorts that she's
the one that's kind of maintaining the
peace here if she wasn't there then
everything would just kind of break
loose
but i think it's also kind of cool that
it was shown in sort of a dream state
right because
what it shows us is how dire the
circumstances are because there was
probably a part of you and i know there
was a part of me that was reading this
and it's like okay but even if cocoa
lost how badly could they
really lose right i mean you've got like
franklin richards and you've got like
all these powerful characters
could they really actually lose here and
the answer is yes they could lose
everything the entire
the entirety of earth could fall right
everybody would die every superhero
across the world and all the mutants
would all be totally destroyed by the
forces of morocco this i think was a
genius idea by jerry dugan because it
shows us how
dire things would get if it didn't work
and so in response to that wolverine's
just kind of like okay right like after
seeing this
he does it grudgingly but he's like okay
like i get what's actually happening
here i get how extreme things are now of
course this leads to wolverine being
served as sushi cipher of course eats a
bit of it and then wolverine immediately
picks up something's wrong and that the
sushi was poisoned
and so when that happens he's just like
somebody poisoned my appetizer right
like who in the heck did this now
eventually you know cypher kind of comes
to do a combination of iska cutting a
hole in his throat right i mean is the
woman that can never lose
the other thing is that you end up
having the white sword right the guy
that can
basically resurrect his 1 000 soldiers
or his 100 soldiers every morning right
so he can basically resurrect the dead
more or less uh who who shows up here
and actually ends up healing cipher
right because we've known for a while
that his power is the ability to heal
but the other thing about this and this
was kind of cool his white sword is
wildly honor bound right he's hugely
honorable because he literally says here
like
poison is is the weapon of a craven
right the weapon of a coward
poison those that you don't think you
can beat what kind of honor is there in
that
right what kind of honor is there in
this whole thing so he's like i the
white sword will not
be party to cowardice and so that's why
he ends up healing cypher and so it's
it's kind of nuts because wolverine
makes this demand of saturnine this is
getting ridiculous it's getting out of
hand they're literally sabotaging us
send us back to gracoa and call the
tournament off and just lock them in
their own realm but the response of
saturnine is do you really intend to
forfeit after the gift that i just gave
you
after i showed you what would happen if
you lost now while all that's going on
right while all this madness is
happening
you end up having apocalypse and genesis
husband and wife
and the the parents of these four
horsemen who are just kind of looking on
and apocalypse is like i see you did
well with the children and she's like i
did my best
right because remember with apocalypse
there is a measure of honor that goes
into it but honor is not the most
important thing the most important thing
is being able to pass testing because
apocalypse probably looks at cypher and
sees him as somebody who has measured
testing and found wanting because if
that was the case he wouldn't just
arbitrarily take part in something
somebody else had he would have
investigated it right he would have been
like i mean is that
is this trustworthy or you know he would
have asked questions the fact that he
couldn't survive
simply being poisoned and had to be
saved by somebody else shows
how weak cipher is in the eyes of
apocalypse and so it's kind of one of
these funny things because you end up
having brian braddock and betsy braddock
who approached saturnine and while
everybody's arguing
it's this kind of discussion one of the
funny things this storm is like pointing
your finger at jim jasper is like if you
had anything to do with this i'll
probably end up beating you up and it's
like okay but like no you wouldn't
either right i mean like he would just
turn you into a teacup and step on you
that's probably what would happen
but saturnine kind of snaps her fingers
and basically mutes everybody
right so they can't hear anybody else
talking and brian braddock kind of makes
this request and saying look like i
request that you set aside their claim
they they like basically declare their
efforts as forfeit they literally
poisoned one of us
right and so because that they are
effectively cheating and saturnine's
initial response is like what you're
asking
is fair right what you're asking is fair
and it is reasonable
hadn't wolverine not tried to kill me
right had he not tried to kill me i
would have granted your request
i would have given you what you wanted
because they cheated but turnabout's
fair play
if wolverine can try to attack me it's
fair for them to try to poison you right
i mean wolverine made the first move he
opened the door for that and so if i let
you stay i have to let them stay as well
you can't have the rules just kind of
favor you because it's just more
convenient that way as it was kind of
nuts
because following that you almost kind
of see a little bit of coming together
of the various characters who were here
that you see one of the horsemen talking
to wolverine and and she's like i never
would have attacked the magistrates like
damn that's that's
pretty ballsy and wolverine's response
is i just want to get my people home and
she's like the singular desire
of every brave soldier right so they're
kind of finding a little bit of common
ground here and that's what's
interesting because i wouldn't i
wouldn't be surprised if by the end of
all this
there's actually a kind of mutual
respect that exists between the forces
of apocalypse and the forces of koko but
that's what's interesting about this
right and that's why stories like this
are so intriguing now what they end up
doing is of course
serving the next cert next uh next
course and it's like everybody take your
seats and they end up presenting these
uh these scarabs stuff with the hearts
of of
pollinate from the rivers of wuhave
cooked to perfection in a reduction of
the greatest wines
from severleth now i'm not even gonna
lie to you guys i might actually eat
some of that
i know it's scarab beetles and that's
gross it's it's probably worth trying
right i mean it's probably
it's probably worth giving a bit of a
taste too now i say that because i'm a
foodie right and what if it tasted like
chicken
i'm just saying you know i'm just saying
right what if it tasted like chicken
here's a real question would you eat
this that's the real question to ask but
with this the scare being served one of
the horsemen is just kind of like
why would you serve me this this sacred
scarab why why would you serve me the
sacred the sacred beetle
and it's kind of a funny reaction right
because he takes his helmet off for a
second and like is literally powered by
a sacred beetle right so
this is jaime reyes it's not but it'd be
cool if it was uh but
you end up having wolverine who just
like eats it in this place it's just
like we can't let the food go to waste
you know and that's what this a lot of
this stuff is it's all basically kind of
a ceremonial thing and so
following that you get to like the main
course itself right and the main course
is and it's really the second time it's
being served in the the house of fallen
banners it's the great horned beast
and the funny thing here is it looks
like an enormous stake right i mean
it's just cut into huge sections and the
white sword is just kind of like you
know i never eat you're right i'm beyond
hunger i don't really need
anything but for this i will make an
exception
and wolverine's like yeah man it's
delicious
this is absolutely amazing but you kind
of see these moments when the two of
them kind of come together or i'm sorry
when these these guys sort of come
together and find some common ground now
one of the funny things that takes place
here
is when young cable actually ends up
talking to apocalypse and his wife now
young cable's familiar with apocalypse
that's one of the the wonky things about
his character
imagine that like your teenage self
imagine like if you're if you're a
person who's 30 years old
imagine your teenage self basically
kills your 30 year old self
and then takes takes the place of your
30 year old self in the modern day
that's basically what cable did right
just kind of take that concept and move
it forward by like 3 000 years and
that's basically what it is right this
is just teenage cable who killed his
adult self
and then is operating here in the modern
day a lot of the experiences that adult
cable had
teenage cable simply hasn't had yet and
that's why you see
this this sort of conversation where
he's talking to where he sits down
between genesis and apocalypse and he's
like man this must be really weird for
you guys
and the response of apocalypse is weird
is a human word right
it's used to describe a reality that
human minds simply just cannot grasp
that's all this concept basically is
right in time you will understand that
when you have more experience now this
kind of pisses off cable a little bit
and the reason why
is because everybody understands that
he's a teenage version of his older self
but everybody here was also familiar
with adult cable and they all know that
adult cable just kind of had
years of experience and wisdom that
nobody else really that that his younger
self just
doesn't have and that's kind of the bane
of his existence right like well you
you'll understand when you're older
right that's basically what he's being
told
universally by everybody right you'll
understand when you're older you'll
understand when you have more experience
and it's it's kind of a true statement
right
it's very much a true statement because
older cable brought a kind of wisdom
to the various characters who were here
that this guy just can't do
following that you have this this this
hilarious and amazing situation where
cable approaches iska right and he's
like your power is that you cannot be
beaten right she's like yep i never have
been beaten and i never will be beaten
he's like that's so cool can you show me
your power and she's like you'll witness
it tomorrow and then you have magic who
shows up and it's just like
but like if we're all gonna be dead
tomorrow like let's see it now
man let's see it right now so they
started putting her power on display
and literally started having her do
things where like she like they put it
through all these tests
and so it's like they have all these
glasses that are kind of turned like
upside down and stuff like that like she
literally fixes them all
like they they have this thing where
they they literally put like a little
thing under a cup and she can't see what
it is
and they're like where is it and she's
like it's right there like literally
every single game of luck
basically she went right like every
single circumstance where she's not
supposed to know things she just
inherently does because that's how her
powers work she is
it's impossible for her to lose and so
she is and this is kind of a comment
that's made by by magic
what if she were to fight domino because
their powers are very much in line with
each other domino is a character who can
bend luck to her favor right so if
domino decided to go play the lottery
she would win
right she would just happen to go to the
right place to buy the right lottery
ticket to play the right numbers and
then she would come out on top that's
just kind of how domino's powers work
she's guided by it right it kind of
guides her decision making with iska it
very much seems to be the same way now i
would surmise
that because of how involved iska's
powers are
and because of the fact that she
operates on a much higher level in a
more grandiose scale right so fighting
massive battles turning entire tides of
conflict different things like that
i would say her power is far more
nuanced and much much
stronger for lack of a better word than
domino's powers are right so she's
basically
a far more capable version of domino
whether that's true or not i don't know
because if a person who can't lose
fights a person who can bend luck to
their side
then it almost kind of seems like an
unstoppable force meeting an immovable
object
who wins in that circumstance or does
everything just explode
that's kind of the question to ask here
but from there you actually end up
switching back over to one of the
horsemen again who's having a
conversation
with red root and this conversation
between the two of them is really
interesting right this horseman is kind
of looking
at isca and they're looking at cable and
they're looking at magic and it's like
these guys are just so weak right like
they're so weak and they're so soft but
then like red root kind of chimes in and
says but i can't help but wonder
and the response of the horseman's like
what i mean they're coddled right
they're unfit
and redroot says perhaps but these
mutants were grown on a world that's
better than ours
so one what if they have a strength that
we just haven't seen yet right
we wear our strength on our sleep we
want our hearts on our sleep we make
sure
everybody around us knows how strong and
capable we are
but if these individuals were raised in
a world where they don't have to display
that
all the time but they're every bit as
strong and capable as we are then what
if we're approaching this with arrogance
what if we're approaching this with
overconfidence if we are that'll be our
undoing
like we readily display that we're
exceedingly strong they hide it right so
like
it's kind of a crazy thing because it's
like that could very well work against
us and the response to this horseman is
set those thoughts aside right like look
at them they are inherently weak
they are not on the same level that we
are and that's entirely true the benefit
of apocalypse's four horsemen is that
they know nothing
but war and chaos they know nothing but
conflict they were born and bred in that
and so if you're a person
that knows nothing but war and chaos all
the time then of course you would
approach a situation or approach a
person
that doesn't readily act the same way
you do and see a kind of weakness
because where they see kindness they see
weakness right that's just kind of the
way that works
because it's just not inherently
necessary to their survival
in the place that they were from
kindness is what got you killed and so
from there you basically end up picking
up with the tournament
actually starting right it actually
begins and saturnine kind of gathers
together
all of the different cards and says okay
right you have all dined well but now
you must return to your chambers and
sleep well for tomorrow
your minds and bodies will be pushed to
the absolute limit as you compete for
your nations and the first
fight that we get here is betsy braddock
captain britain
versus isca the unbeatable but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and i will catch you all later
peace
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you